[Music]
and videos launching the RTX 4070 and
we're reviewing it so it comes out
officially tomorrow it's priced at 600
MSRP they are commonly going to be two
slot form factor cards so this is a two
slot card finally we're coming back down
to something more reasonable for
thickness and a 600 price tag that puts
it 200 below the existing 4070 ti so to
just recap what nvidia's got right now
it's 490 at 1600 MSRP 4080 at 1200 MSRP
and we were really not fond of the 4080
4070 TI at originally it was going to be
900 and a 4080 12 gigabyte so we're
gonna have two but it's a 470 TI and
it's 800 and now this at 600. so uh this
is NVIDIA getting as close to the
mid-range as they can while still
creating a clear Avenue for people who
are looking to spend 500 bucks to go
okay fine I'll buy it that's probably
their angle here so today we're looking
at the game performance the thermal is
the power of the frequency and the fan
response to The Thermals we will also be
looking at Ray tracing and aside from
the obvious generational comparisons uh
dating back we have GTX 1070 and RTX
2070 in here we will also be talking
about the 3080 and the 6950 XT in
particular there's a lot of other stuff
there too but those two especially are
interesting here before that this video
is brought to you by thermal Grizzly
thermal Grizzlies hydronaut and cryonaut
thermal paste are high performing
thermal interfaces for use on CPUs and
gpus you can bring an old card back to
Peak Performance by replacing it and
doing preventative maintenance and
thermal Grizzlies hydronaut is ideal for
water Cooling and Air coolant for new
and old cards alike Crow not paste is
one of the top performing pace for
extreme overclocking with CPUs and gpus
and has been used in several world
record scoring machines learn more at
the link in the description below so
starting with some of the Core specs
just quickly this thing has 588 Cuda
cores or fp32 scores and that is down
from 76.80 on the 4070 TI the 4070 keeps
the 12 gigabyte frame buffer it's got 12
gigabytes of memory it's using gddr6x
and uh on a 192-bit interface that ends
up yielding a 504 gigabyte per second
memory bandwidth so this number was one
that Nvidia was clearly a little bit
concerned about publishing because it
immediately sort of noted to the press
that the L2 cache is higher with Ada
Lovelace this is not new to the 4070
it's just new for the 40 series and that
L2 cache is able to compensate for some
of the memory bandwidth so L2 is at 36
megabytes here on the 4070 TI it's 48
megabytes and then for reference the
3070 TI was four megabytes but that was
one of their points as for our points uh
the main things to be interested in from
a mechanical perspective or simply that
it can finally come come down to two
eight pins if you didn't like the 12
volt high power connector but the Fe
model does run 12 volt high power with a
splitter to 2 8. but partner models will
commonly run two eights and the 12 volt
high power spec or the requirement is
different here so remember that there
are different types of ratings for
cables for 12 volt high power they're
not all the same there are 300 watt
supported power supplies and cables and
there are 600 watts this is one where
you can get away with 300 watts as long
as it's pinned appropriately for the
pcie5 spec but that's a different topic
entirely so pricing on the market this
is important because the Market's
changed a lot and it makes it a really
tough place for the 4070 to compete to
go over what's currently out there the
number one thing for you to pay
attention to is probably going to be the
6950xt we saw a Newegg still has a lot
of them they're available from 600 to
660 or so depending on who's you buy and
a lot of them have 30 off instant
discount codes Amazon has similar stock
of 6950x these so this will be a direct
price competitor despite its original
price being over a thousand dollars for
the 6950 XT it's a big drop also from
AMD the 6800 XT is available for around
540 to 600 right now from Nvidia their
3080 would be a good value competitor
but it's basically gone for New Stock
you'd have to buy used for the most part
for used prices a quick check on eBay
reveals a few listings for about 500 to
600 bucks buy it now for the 10 gigabyte
model you can probably find stuff
cheaper as well we didn't look too hard
there the RTX 3070 is still available
new for 500 but you shouldn't buy that
at this point probably we'll show you
today that the 40 70 it's about 30
faster than the 3070 and if the gap's
only 100 bucks
it's not the best value so uh we're
going to get into the benchmarks now for
some quick benchmarking philosophies as
usual we're looking at and most
interested in the relative difference
between the Cards on the charts so that
will allow us to establish the
hierarchical ranking from a percent
scaling perspective and additionally
when we're looking at that we'll be
looking at three different resolutions
1080 14 44k as usual but the value here
is that looking at all three of these
because this card can scale on all three
of them it's not like a 490 where
bottlenecks easily we will be able to
see some instances where the 3080 either
pulls ahead or falls behind depending on
the resolution making it a much more
interesting comparison uh and then we'll
do the power thermal frequency fan and
all that stuff today as well so let's
get started with some charts other than
path tracing and cyberpunk our next
heaviest workload is actually Total War
Warhammer 3 at 4K for this testing the
RTX 4070 Fe ran at 56 FPS average with
lows at 43 and 37. that places it just
behind the RX 6950xc from AMD currently
actually about 650 Bucks new and ahead
of the 6800 XT by about 10 percent the
6800 XT is still available new for
around 560 or so plus or minus at the
time of writing as an upgrade option the
4070 jumps over the 1080 TI by 65 or the
3060 by 95 percent but the 3080 leads
the 4070 impressively here with the 64
FPS average and lows similarly ahead to
establish a 14 Advantage compared to the
3070 the generational by name jump is
about 28 percent in exchange for 20 more
money than the original MSRP at least
that's somewhat Tamer than past launches
but we'll talk about value later finally
the 4070 TI's 67 FPS average result
holds a 19 lead over the 40 70 for at
least 33 more money the gulf between the
40 90 and everything else remains
staggering with the 4090 holding 120 22
percent lead over the new 40 70. it's an
entirely different class of Hardware
that makes sense for the price but it
didn't used to be that way flagships are
now segmented further away from the rest
of the stack to make them look at least
on nvidia's side more like an actual
Flagship they're trying to give you a
reason to buy it previously you'd look
at a Titan card and it was a couple
percent better than the best gaming
cards at the same generation and it was
often hundreds of dollars more expensive
so that much has changed significantly
here's the chart for 1440p we have a ton
more data that we had to remove from
this chart just to make it legible so
we've eliminated all the modern low end
cards like the 1650 in order to a better
accommodate upgrade possibilities like
the older 580 and the GTX 1070 you can
find the low end stuff in our other
videos but the RTX 4070 ran at 112 FPS
average here which puts it again ahead
of the 6800 XT and behind the 6950 XT
this time the 6950 XT is about 10
percent ahead the 3080 holds a similar
lead over the 40 70 and the 40 70 TI is
about 22 improved over the new 40 70.
against the 3070 we're seeing a 32
uplift this time up from 28 at 4K so
it's climbing 1080p has the 490 still in
a ridiculous position considering we're
so low on resolution now that it's
starting to choke on the CPU limit
directing attention to the new 4070
though the card Advance is
generationally by name at least by 36
percent over the 30 70. each resolution
reduction is showing about a four
percentage Point increase in improvement
over the 30 70 for this game the 3080 is
now about tied to the 4070 with a 6950
XT maintaining its 10 lead moving to a
4070 TI gives about a 22 increase from
the 40 70 the same as the 1440p result
in Tomb Raider at 4K the 4070 landed at
94 FPS average this places it behind the
3080 and all three shown metrics but in
a functional sense they're basically
equal the 4070 does lead the former
twelve hundred dollar Flagship 2080 TI
though for what that's worth by about 25
percent after five or so years from its
launch more appropriately competition
from the similarly priced 6950 XT and
6800 XT cards is fierce in this title
with both pushing above the 40 70. the
4070 TI leads by 23 percent similar to
Total Warhammer and the new 4070 leads
the 30 70 by 35 percent more than we saw
in Total War at 1440p the RTX 4070 ran
at 170 FPS average and led the 3080 by
about 6 FPS they're roughly in the same
spot for averages and lows and the 3080
remains one of nvidia's better cards
just like the old 1080 TI that we also
have on this chart as for the 4070 TI
that would get you an increase about 21
similar to the past few games as for the
4080 though on the 490 they're both
truncated by the resolution here because
the binders shifting to the CPU at this
resolution looking at older cards it
Stacks like this the the 4070 leads the
30 70 by 39 percent the 2070 by 96
percent and the 1070 by about 200
percent at 1080p we're approaching the
CPU bottleneck on the 4070 it's just
ahead of the 3080 and 30 90 which tracks
with some of the resolution uplift we've
plotted elsewhere but the 4070 TI on the
op for NVIDIA are all bounded off of a
bottleneck this isn't a useful chart
because it's two constrains to draw
conclusions so let's move forward in
Final Fantasy 14 at 4K the RTX 4070 ran
at 91 FPS average which plants it just
ahead of the 2080 TI and behind the 6800
XT once again it's also behind the 3080
which carries a nine percent lead here
the Boost over the 30 70 is 27 percent
falling in line with most of the other
results competitively the 6950 XT poses
excellent value if you can still get it
around 650 which right now you can but
note that the 6950xc's lows are reduced
as compared to the 47 DTI and that's
true for some other AMD cards in this
Benchmark as well moving to 1440p and
Final Fantasy the 40 90 and 4080 were
removed from the charts as they're
firmly against the CPU bottleneck the
4070 TI is slightly below it but still
bounces off of it in some areas of the
sequence the RTX 4070 non-ti ran at 195
FPS average with lows at 116 and 80 FPS
that's about what we'd expect for lows
when looking at the neighbors like the
once again tied RTX 3080 the 6950 XT
maintains its roughly 10 to 11 lead here
with a 30 70 giving up a 30 boost to the
40 70. but this game is playable on a
lot of devices all the way down to the
old 8 gigabyte RX 580. it's staying
above 50 FPS average there 1080p is CPU
bound so we'll skip that one and move to
the next game next up we're revisiting
strange Brigade for the useful
perspective that it provides despite
being low in player base we've kept it
around because the test can sometimes
reveal really unique behaviors about GPU
and it will do that here today and
that's especially because it's available
with both Vulcan and dx12 and it's
proven to be well optimized overall
starting with dx12 at 4K the RTX 4070
ran at 126 FPS average with lows paced
reasonably they're timed okay the 3080
climbs to about a 17 lead that's great
positioning for a former Flagship AMD is
6950 XT also shines now posting a
massive 40 lead over the 40 70. this is
exactly why we still use strange Brigade
the results can't be extrapolated
broadly the 40 won't be everywhere
obviously but they can show another side
to the story which is that games aren't
monoliths and they all behave a little
differently AMD takes off in general in
this test the 6800 XT holds its own lead
of 26 here over the 4070 and compared to
older cards the 4070 leads the 30 70 by
now only 23 percent the 2070 by 77
percent and the 1070s 44 FPS result by
only 186 percent only here just because
it's lower than last time still a lot
1440p shows that this game had plenty
more in the tank for the 40 90 and 4080.
the 40 70s 238 FPS average result here
allows the 4070 TI a lead of 28 the 4080
a staggering lead of 77 and the 40 90 is
starting to hit limits of the CPU so it
gets truncated a little bit as for the
comparison points the 3080 holds a seven
percent Advantage so it has been reduced
from the 4K number and the 6800 XT has a
17 advantage over the 40 70. we're
seeing a 30 advantage over the 30 70s
183 FPS average results when moving to
the new Ada Lovelace 40 70. and here's
why this game is interesting from the
perspective of studying the hardware
rather than the game itself at 1080p the
3080 is now below the 40 70. the 3080
was leading in the prior two resolutions
but its lead was reduced at 1440p and
now again at 1080p the 470 TI is about
29 ahead here with the 40 90 the 4080
and the 700 xdx all hitting the CPU
bottleneck the 79 XTX isn't necessarily
actually ahead here we would need to
fully unbind them to figure that out but
as for the 70 class cards the 4070 leads
the 30 70 by 40 in this particular
Benchmark as it's doing
disproportionately better in 1080P with
this setup so depending on the scenario
it looks like the 4070 is scaling
positively as resolution decreases we'll
briefly look at the 1440p Vulcan results
as well one of the more interesting
entries here is the 3080 which runs at
241 FPS average and ends up leading the
4070 by about 40 FPS or 20 advantage
that's pretty big for the 3080. the same
is true for the 6800 XT and the 4070 TI
holds the predictable 22 Improvement
generationally the 4070 offers these
improvements 18 over the 30 70 67 of the
2070 and 170 over the 1070 Horizon zero
Dawn is up next first tested at 4K the
RTX 4070 Fe ran at 82 FPS average here
with lows again fine we're not seeing
any red flags demanding deeper frame
time plots the RTX 4070 TI is 97 FPS
average result establishes an 18 lead
it's a little lower than we've seen
before and once again the RTX 3080
maintains equivalence with the 4070.
also once again the 6800 XT and the 6950
XT remain ahead and the lead over the
3070 remains about 30 percent so not
much change from the other games at
1440p the 4070 ran at 156 FPS average
and held a slight lead over even the RTX
3090 the 3080 now dips below the 4070
with the 4070 holding a 10 lead so the
4070s relative performance improves at
least in this one as the resolution
decreases the 4070 TI is only 12 percent
ahead of the 4070 here but that's
because we're becoming CPU bound at
around 175 FPS so it doesn't have full
room to scale and that 12 percent number
isn't actually the full picture it's not
representative of reality it's bound CS
goes up next this is the lightest weight
game we currently Benchmark for gpus but
we still see differences pop up for the
mid-range we haven't run the full speed
of GPS for this game yet actually we
added it for Intel Arc but allowing the
4070 to run in this one put it in an
uncontested position because again it's
just lower on Parts till now at 4K the
470 ran at 195 of PSI average with
lowest space consistently this isn't CPU
bottleneck actually it's something we
can demonstrate in the next chart but
since we just added CS go to our testing
you don't have much to compare this to
other than maybe a 1660 TI which just
kind of gives you a sense for scale but
we recognize it's not that useful yet
we're adding more to it it's not worth
spending much more time on CS go for
those reasons but at 1440p we can at
least show that the 40 70s 357 FPS
average results here illustrates there
was CPU Headroom still at 4K now that
we're through the rasterized games we're
going to look at a couple of Ray Trace
samples now we are currently working on
revising our GPU test suite and that
includes adding cyberpunk path tracing
in you may have just seen our video
about it if you haven't you should check
it out but that currently only has a 40
90 for the data set because it came in
one day before this review actually
filming I don't know like 12 hours
before this video is going to go up so
we'll be adding that in soon but for now
we'll look at a couple of Mainstays and
standards for RT now we're back to Ray
tracing again but this time with a
fuller set of data so RT tomb Raiders up
now this is a different test than the
earlier Tomb Raider test so remember
that the numbers are not comparable
between them because the previous charts
didn't use Ray tracing features over the
years we've actually had a lot of people
get confused by that so these are
different data sets with rt Shadows
enabled there's a drop in overall FPS
but not as much as you'd see in
cyberpunk this is the lightest way RT
feature test we currently run it
diminishes the advantage of cards that
are otherwise strong and Ray tracing and
it serves to equalize with a heavier
focus on rasterization but our other
tests fill the Gap to more fully
leverage the advantages and here's that
chart the RTX 4070 ran at 55 of PSI
average with rt enabled and highest
settings that has it about equal with
the 6900 XT which is now fallen in
relative ranking and it's also within
the error of the RTX 3080. the 6950xt
maintains a technical lead but not a
meaningful one increasing the budget by
30 percent to get an RTX 4070 TI would
yield at 26 percent uplift in
performance so it's really not a great
proposition for that cost for the
upgrade at 1440p the new 4070 ran at
about 104 FPS average which puts it at
the same level as the RTX 3090 and just
ahead of the rx6950xt it's finally
overtaking the 6950 XT after all of
those charts and it took RT features to
do it as for the 4070 TI it's 23 lead
and 128 FPS average is diminished from
the 4K lead we've seen enough Tomb
Raider at this point so the 1080p chart
is brief the most noteworthy thing here
is that the 40 70 TI's lead versus the
40 70 dropped to just 20 percent down
from 26 at 4K previously so if you're
playing on a lower resolution display
the benefit of the ti could be less
significant than say at 4K depending on
the game you're working with control is
up next this is tested as raw Ray
tracing no dlss or FSR it's a pure like
for like comparison in that way you
could obviously enable one of these
Technologies but the point here is
relative comparison not absolute you can
see our separate dlss content as well
like the one we just published yesterday
for cyberpunk for more information in
control at 4K the RTX 4070 ran at 32 FPS
average which positioned it behind the
3080 by actually a lot it's about 20
percent at least the 3080 improved by 20
over the new 40 70. but because these
numbers are so low that's why you're
seeing these larger percentages and
exactly why relative comparisons matter
it's also about tied with the 6950 XT
and averages and lows and the 4070 TI
has a 24 lead here over the 40 70 but
really the 3080 is sort of the star of
this show at 1440p the RTX 4070 ran at
67 FPS average definitely playable and
that had it again nearly equal with the
6950 XT or behind the 3080. the 3080s
lead was reduced to 10 percent here but
it's still a clear lead now we're moving
to power testing so for power testing we
are logging the power consumption
actively this is really in there they
may have finally firmed up that
connector I don't know uh or I or we
just plugged it in a while uh for power
we're gonna be looking at the actual
power consumption at the rails so that's
going to be pcie 12 volt at the top we
are looking at the pcie slot power Draw
2 and we're going to be doing that
through a full system workload so let's
move to the Chart we measured the RTX
4070s power consumption at about 200
Watts when fully loaded and under stock
condition for the founders Edition model
that puts it at about the same power
consumption as the 3060 TI below the
3070 with a 9 reduction and lower than
the 4070 TI by 90 Watts overclocking the
4070 to its maximum allowed power offset
pushed it to 225 Watts or about an 11
increase in maximum power consumption
this card is on the more efficient end
of nvidia's lineup at least when stock
with the previous 3070 posting were
sufficiency really to no one's surprise
it has been a generation now and that's
because the performance per watt is
simply lower the 4070 is an improvement
in this respect as the Ada GPU
architecture has been in general and
considering this is a full complete
power virus type load we're not really
concerned or impressed too much one way
or the other it seems predictable at
this point now for thermal's fan and
frequency the main thing to look for
here is going to be the v-bios
programming the behavior in the firmware
and we can tell that for some aspect
through the fan curve so uh fan
hysteresis is one of the number one
things that can be screwed up in AV bios
profile for a card and that will follow
the temperature targets it has certain
fan characteristics for ramp and dram
and hysteresis sort of describes the
idea of a the latency or the lag of the
fan ramp versus the temperature ramp you
don't want a whole bunch of crazy fan up
and down Behavior with really spiky
responses to thermals because it is a
terrible user experience so that's
something we look for Here additionally
we will be looking for the GPU core the
hot spot and the memory thermals and for
each of those numbers as a reminder
temperature isn't a fire strike score 3D
Market score that just gets spit out of
some application it is highly dependent
on every single variable that you test
with which goes all the way down to the
room ambient temperature so ours is all
extremely controlled and there's a
pretty good Baseline look at at the card
let's go to the charts here's the chart
the GPU core temperature spiked quickly
on load initialization as always and
quickly hit steady state at about 65
degrees Celsius and a controlled ambient
environment of 21 degrees that's more
than acceptable for core temperature and
indicates to us the V bios Target of the
Fe card The Hot Spot temperature plots
next for this one the GPU hotspot landed
at about 77 to 78 degrees Celsius
establishing a Delta of 13 degrees
Celsius that's fine it's not impressive
once again but we've seen a lot of gpus
and CPUs over the years that are in the
20 plus degree range for Deltas we just
saw GPU not long ago that had a 30
degree range from average to the hot
spot so this is far better than that and
it's completely acceptable memory
temperatures are last for these they hit
and held a steady state of 70 degrees
Celsius which is well within spec we
typically want memory temperatures to be
under 90c depending on the type of
memory it is some can go up to like 105
but this is enough to allow some
Headroom and flexibility as the
components AIDS paste ages and the case
may be clogging with dust ignoring noise
momentarily and strictly with respect to
these thermals that v card is achieving
an acceptable performance level it may
be worse at a relative sense when
compared to something like an Asus
aftermarket card but it's not bad enough
that we'd advise against purchasing the
Fe it's a big swing from the founders
Edition designs of your like the 910
Series where we were actively very
strongly discouraging their purchase
because they were terrible thermally and
this has mostly resolved that and now
we'll quickly show The Fan response to
that profile adding to the previous plot
the fan kicked in within a few seconds
of the load Spike which is typical the
fan wrap was mostly immediate Landing at
about 1450 RPM instantaneously after
that it had a slower ramp to 1600 which
is standard typically you want to avoid
fan hysteresis that causes rapid ramp
and dram or chaotic speed adjustments as
these behaviors are the most noticeable
to the user in this instance the fan
adjusts to hold the V bios temperature
Target and then it stays steady this
chart is for the frequency during a
constant 3D Mark Port Royal workload
frequency changes depending on what
specifically the card is doing the
thermal load also affects this and so
does the power budget and of course the
software this data is from the same
chart as our thermal test a moment ago
so it correlates directly the 4070 held
about 2700 to 2745 megahertz in this
workload for our test including that
steady state although there's some
frequency Decay over time with heat
buildup it's insignificant in this
situation we're not dropping meaningful
clocks due to ineffective thermal design
or throttling because of thermals we're
running into the power budget well
either they've beaten us into confusion
with the GPU prices at this point and
the naming and the shifting of the names
and the shifting of the actual GPU cores
as they are assigned to those names or
the 4070s position isn't as bad as the
4080s launch positioning for the pricing
is one of those too
one of them has a lot more words and the
other one is not as bad as the 4080s
launch positioning uh let's go over some
quick ad hoc percentages that we talked
about earlier so recap and we noticed
about roughly a 22 increase with the
4070 TI versus the 40 70 plus or minus
about six percentage points depending on
which application you're looking at we
noticed some really interesting behavior
in strange Brigade which is exactly why
it's in there uh it particularly favored
the 6950 XT in a really strong way for
average FPS versus the 4070s so that was
interesting to see but it was not
characteristic of all performance just
sort of a breakout interesting piece but
that 22 increase to the 4070 TI it's not
a compelling upgrade if you're
interested in the 500 to 600 class it is
really not worth two hundred dollars if
you're already kind of maxing your
budget so don't feel like you have to
stretch to get that if you're
uncomfortable past 600. the increase
against the 30 70 was often about 30
plus or minus a bit and again against
the 1070 was closer to 200 on average
which makes sense but the 6950 XT and
the 3080 tended to hold the lead the
6800 XT was also nearby and these are
the ones that you should really be
paying attention to so the 3080 is kind
of hard to find now but from Quick
glances on retailers the 6950 XCS are
available new still and they maybe
they're dumping them if they're I don't
know AMD has something in the pipeline
or whatever it is but the prices are are
pretty good on those cars there's a lot
of discount codes and it's not like the
BS mail-in rebate stuff it's like you
type the code and it gives you money off
uh which brings the pricing down pretty
competitive it's like basically
identical to this pricing but better
performance so you should really be
looking at the 6950 XT right now because
uh speaking for personally myself I
haven't looked at that price for a while
a couple months whenever we did the last
review maybe and probably a lot of
people haven't looked at it since it
came out so if you've been out of the
loop on that go look at the new pricing
before you just buy this instantly
because it has changed a lot the cards
are not selling like they used to
there's some good deals out there if
you're okay with used take a look at the
3080s for this card specifically for the
Fe card 4070 the thermal design is
competent here we thus far have not
found any major issues now we may do a
separate full mechanical piece on this
it depends on time what we what else we
have in the pipeline but thus far from
our test in uh this thing's doing at
least well meaning there's anywhere
close to Thermal throttling four hour
sample at least with GB thermals which
I'm only qualifying because of the AMD
issue with the 7800 XTX
no GPU thermal issues the memory
thermals were within a reasonable
expectation they're well below spec so
we think they've done well here
hysteresis and tuning on the fan curve
is competent and good uh it is in fact a
compliment to call it expected that's
what you want and all of that seems fine
the size is certainly more tenable and
this puts Nvidia or at least keeps it in
the position it's gained with the 4090
Fe where and the 3080 Fe where suddenly
it is competing with its own board
partners because now it's making designs
that aren't completely inane and stupid
like the old reference card and Founders
designs were they were just thermal
nightmares compared to everything else
you're dropping clocks comparatively
because that's how boost works and
because they're running warm now partner
models may still be better in a relative
sense we haven't tested them but this is
not objectively bad that's what we're
getting on here so that's it we've given
you pretty much all the numbers and go
take a look at the gpus that don't say
40 in front of them because the
pricing's changed a lot the companies
are kind of desperate you're going to
find some really good deals out there
and if you haven't looked just because
it doesn't say 40 so it feels bad
because it's old or something or just
because the prices were inane a couple
six six seven months ago uh then it's
time to look again before you commit to
something like this one but that's it
we've given you everything to work with
thanks for watching as always subscribe
for more go to store.camersaccess.net to
grab a project mat like this one and uh
check out our Voodoo 3dfx revisit if you
haven't seen it it's really fun video
subscribe for more we'll see you all
next time